a federal judge has yet to decide on
whether to appoint a special Master to
review the documents seized by the FBI
from former president Trump's Florida
home last month on Friday the judge
released a more detailed list of what
was taken it includes more than a
hundred classified documents and more
than a thousand media clippings Robert
Costa has the latest
the detailed list of evidence taken from
the former president's Florida estate
revealed 48 folders marked as classified
that were found empty some legal experts
say that likely alarms investigators the
government is under an obligation to
find out
where are those documents who has seen
those documents
where are they now in all the list shows
Trump possessed 103 documents marked as
classified
27 that were marked top secret secret or
confidential were found in his personal
office at Mar-A-Lago 76 more were seized
from his storage room some former
intelligence officials have told CBS
news they worry about how documents were
mixed in with Trump's everyday items
clothes photos and news clippings
Trump's claim this week that he had
Declassified documents was criticized by
his former Attorney General Republican
bill Barr if in fact he sort of stood
over scores of boxes not really knowing
what was in them and said I hereby
declassify everything in here that would
be such an abuse
that and show such recklessness that
it's almost worse than taking the
documents responding to the new list of
evidence the former president spokesman
has sailed it as a product of a smash
and grab by the FB AI while Trump's
son-in-law continued to downplay the
stakes he was the president United
States he had the highest clearance in
the world so I don't know if like this
may be a paperwork issue meanwhile here
in Washington the grand jury
investigating January 6 is now hearing
from former top White House aides to
Trump yesterday the former White House
counsel Pat cipolloni and his Deputy
appeared as that probe continues to plow
ahead with its work almost entirely out
of public view for CBS Saturday morning
Robert Costa Washington